les migrations 4e partie aujourd'hui les
migrations
international toujours comme support à
cet exposé le dictionnaire de géographie
aux éditions
Hatier en 2012 on estime le nombre de
migrants internationaux environ 240
millions de personnes dans le monde soit
environ 3 % de la population mondiale
qui n'habite pas dans le pays dans
lequel elle est
né cette internationale qualifié parfois
de nomadisme planétaire est à mettre en
relation avec la mondialisation
évidemment à la fin du 19e siècle et au
début du 20e siècle les flux étaient en
proportion de population mondiale bien
plus massive qu'aujourd'hui on constate
depuis les années 1970 une progression
numérique globale des migrations avec
des flux sans cesse plus planétaires et
des populations plus variées des
travailleurs des étudiants mais aussi
des réfugiés et des familles
donc le phénomène est plus riche plus
complexe bien qu'il ne soit pas
forcément en terme de proportion plus
important le contexte dans lequel
évidemment ces nouvell migration
apparaissent est
important la progression de ces flux est
liée à la mondialisation de l'économie
d'une part qui creuse inégalités entre
les territoires et donc les motifs de
migration
ces mouvements sont facilités évidemment
par la diversification des moyens de
transport et la baisse de leurs coûts
par existence à l'échelle de la planète
de réseaux actifs dont les revenus
alimentent les économies des pays
émetteurs ces migrations peuvent être
suscité par les images de richesse du
Nord véhiculé par les médias vers les
pays du Sud par évidemment la télévision
mais aussi des réseaux sociaux et
d'internet on parle de filière
migratoire pour qualifier l'ensemble
formé par un flux important et tous les
éléments qui ont concouru à sa création
les transferts finan financiers ou
remise à savoir les sommes d'argent
envoyé par les immigrés à leurs
famillees resté au pays jouent souvent
un rôle considérable dans la vie des
populations et pays concernés
participant à leur intégration dans
l'économie mondialisé évidemment cela
pourrait apparaître comme scandaleux
mais mais quand on analyse les flux
financiers économiqu entre les deux
zones entre l'hémisphère nord et
l'hémisphère sud on constate évidemment
comme vous le voyez sur l'infographie
qui vous est présentée ici que pour
chaque eurau que gagn les pays du Sud
grâce au pays du Nord ils envoient en
fait 2 € dans ces mêm pays du
Nord ainsi le monde fonctionne comme un
système migratoire formé par un emble de
flux de personnes entre pays de départ
de transit et d'arrivée mais aussi de
relations financière culturell lié à ces
flux des systèmes migratoires régionaux
s'individualisent qui s'explique
notamment par des liens historiques et
culturels de proximité et de
différentiel de développement ainsi
l'Afrique va surtout fonctionner avec
l'Europe les États-Unis avec l'Amérique
latine
et l'Afrique du Sud avec l'Afrique
australe les migrations internationale
participe à la mondialisation culturelle
à l'exportation d'un même modèle
culturel d'un point de vue spatial elles
peuvent aboutir aussi à la création dans
le pays d'accueil d'Ilo culturel dans
lequel se regroupent les nouveaux
arrivants ils y trouvent des facilités
d'insertion voire d'intégration et une
forme de solidarité qui permet de lutter
contre l'isolement et la margin
les chinaton ou les quartiers
chinois dans différents pays d'Europe et
d'Amérique du Nord mais aussi par
exemple little Italie à manattan ou le
quartier africain de la Goutte d'Or à
Paris ou Matongé à Bruxelles sont autant
de ces îos culturelles dont la présence
marque le caractère très cosmopolite
c'est-à-dire résultant de peuples
d'origine différentes des métropoles de
la
planète
les migrations internationales ont
généralement deux grandes causes les
causes politiques et les causes
économiques en ce qui concerne les
causes politiques les exemples dans
l'histoire sont très nombreux il s'agit
par exemple des 9 millions d'Allemands
qui refluèrent de la Prusse orientale et
des régions de l'Est de l'Allemagne en
1944- 1945 à la suite de l'avancée de
l'armée rouge on peut également citer
les populations juives soviétiques qui
ont gagné l'État d'Israël au moment de
sa création
ou bien les B people population
originaire de la Péninsula indochinoise
qui quitt leur pays sur des embarcations
de forune ou encore les Rand qui en 1994
ont tenté d'échapper au Lutes
interethnique en trouvant refuge auxï
aujourd'hui République démocratique du
Congo évidemment avec l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui on pourra éviter de faire
le lien avec le cas
syrien aujourd'hui de réfugiés ou de
réfugiés politiques les individus qui
quittent un état dans lequel leur
sécurité leur liberté ne sont plus
assuré et trouve refuge dans un pays
étranger qui les accueille et leur
accorde parfois un statut
spécifique on parlera aussi de
migration avec une cause politique
lorsque la migration est forcée
c'està-dire que les individus n'ont pas
le choix de quitter leur pays le pouvoir
politique en place les oblige à
partir les migration pour raisons
économiques peuvent nous apparaître les
plus importantes mais ce n'est pas
forcément le cas alors il y aura tout
d'abord les migrations de la fin
évidemment les individus vont migrer
parce qu'ils n'ont pas euh les
ressources suffisantes que pour subvenir
à leur premier besoin qui est de se
nourrir et ensuite nous aurons aussi les
migration de travailleurs ceux qui sont
sans emploi et qui vont essayer de
trouver un emploi dans un pays où la
situation économique est plus favorable
évidemment on pensera directement à des
flux euh de personnes entre pays où la
situation économique est moins bonne
vers des zones où la situation
économique est meilleure évidemment ça
ne doit pas occulter le fait que
certains pays font venir de la main
d'œuvre étrangère pour subvenir à leur
propre manque de main d'œuvre sur leur
marché du travail
national cette vidéo est terminée
n'oubliez pas de vous rendre avant que
nous nous guittions de vous rendre sur
schoog afin de réaliser le petit quiz de
fin de vidéo à bientôt